well you know you have to look at fungi
fungi are primary
decomposers that means they can only
live on decaying life that suggests to
me that they are late evolving or at
least not early evolving mushrooms are
very soft bodied and so are all fungi
there is no record in no fossil record
of a mushroom older than 40 million
years well that's a tiny fraction of the
time life has been on the earth now when
I asked a paleontologist about this he
said well they're soft and bodied and
they don't fossilize easily but hey we
have black worm from the gun-sling
Church of South Africa they're 4.3
billion years old
if they left a trace in the fossil
record you'd think there would be more
of a trace of mushrooms
if you D condition your presuppositions
and just look at the mushroom it looks
to me number one as though it is capable
of surviving an extraterrestrial
environment in other words if you have
mushrooms spores and you want to store
them for long-term longevity you seek an
environment as much like outer space as
you can find you store them in liquid
nitrogen at minus 200 degrees and they
will last virtually forever
if you look at the color of Strawberry
Avensis fourth that's in the brown guild
mushroom family the spores are deep
purple almost black that's the color you
would paint a spacecraft if you wanted
to absorb long long
way of radiation if you look at the
sport you know what is it it's a packet
of crystallized
DNA a single mature stropharia events
this mushroom when it's for you lading
will shed up to 3 million spores a
minute for up to 2 weeks 3 million
spores a minute for 2 weeks then these
things are microscopic so small that the
perturbations and agitation of air
molecules which are called Brownian
motion can actually percolate these
things into the outer atmosphere where
them energetic cosmic events can
actually detach them from the
terrestrial medium and they slowly like
planetary dandruff or something drift
off into space well I I always it seems
so obvious to me maybe because I live in
Hawaii but the most predictable major
revolution in biology that you can
imagine is of course within a few years
that will be realized that the earth is
an island that's all
but the biota that is present here much
of it probably drifted in in cosmic
debris when stars go supernova planets
are destroyed it's a cliche of cosmic
consciousness to say you know the atoms
in your body were once in the hearts of
distant stars well if that's true then
some of the atoms in your body were once
in the parts of distant planets and some
vanishingly small fraction may have been
part of the biota of extraterrestrial
ecosystems the other thing about the
mushroom that's very suggestive to me
is it appears to be oratory there is a
place of perspective from which you can
look at it that it appears to be not an
organism but an artifact
it is incredibly well designed at a very
high level of design criteria for
example on this planet one of the most
advanced ethical systems we've been able
to evolve is Buddhism which teaches
vegetarianism if a Buddhist could design
their own genome they would become a
fungus because a fungus is a primary
decomposer it's the only car molas place
in the entire food chain there is no
Karma for the fungi they don't destroy
any life whatsoever so and so here you
have this thing designed to traverse
extraterrestrial space occupying a
carmella snitch in the ecosystem and
when complex with a mammalian nervous
system a go act Aryan archives of
historical data becomes accessible we
have only known about DNA since 1950
less than 50 years and we're already
confidently talking about completely
redesigning the human genome and so
forth and so on well if we pursue along
these lines for 500 years we will look
the way we want to look and you know you
trivially we may all want to be Keanu
leaves or something but once the
cultural agenda tests in if say Buddhism
to
over in the presence of an advanced
molecular genetics then we could design
ourselves into a caramel ass nation the
universe I I wish that we could bring I
don't know who it is but the content of
the mushroom experience which was what
launched your question it's so evidently
alien and non-human and self referential
to a world we don't know that to me it
would require a commission and several
years of study to decide that this thing
is not an extraterrestrial our notions
of extraterrestrials to this point have
been incredibly self reflexive I once
you have fully in Grasse the size of the
universe and the amount of time that is
available then the idea that someone
would come in a mental in a mental shift
with an interest in your growth
industrial output and the desire to cure
cancer is absolutely preposterous that's
such a culture bound notion it's like
expecting them to arrive with a load of
pizzas ready for delivery the trick is
going to be to recognize the
extra-terrestrial the very notion alien
means unfamiliar so it's it's not going
to be like we think it is the real task
will be to recognize it and we have
discovered after only a thousand years
that toxic metal based technologies are
faithful and we have pushed our entire
planet into planetary crisis by coming
to this realization rather late in the
game
if if long-term survival is the name of
the game for intelligent life in the
universe
then the way we're doing it is not the
way to do it it's going to have to be
non-polluting biologically based
molecularly based so forth and so on and
as you run down the list the mushroom
begins to look more and more like the
real thing and then of course the
content of the of the experience is so
different from other psychedelics and so
it's so other oriented that I am puzzled
that we've been at this now nearly 30
years and we still don't have a
consensus I don't think it I don't know
what it is is it that when you take the
mushroom you lose all ability to then
operate in the world of straight
judgement and understanding it's very
puzzling but I think probably the biota
of the earth is riddled with
extraterrestrial genes if not organism
and possibly intelligences but they're
not interested in your fetal tissue or
putting implants and you were taking you
up and slicing you up on very large
scales surgical wards I find all that
paranoid and pathological I can talk
about that if you want but it's not
really our subject